tráfico de personas en la frontera sur
de México se recrudece autoridades del
país Azteca encontraron vivos a 175
migrantes en la caja de un camión en el
estado de Chiapas al sur del territorio
mexicano con llantos y golpes al
vehículo los migrantes lograron llamar
la atención de los agentes migratorios
que cuando el vehículo fue detenido en
un retén lograron sacar al centenar de
personas que viajaban hacinados el
Instituto Nacional de Migración
autoridad encargada de vigilar los
flujos migratorios en el país publicó un
comunicado anunciando el rescate de los
migrantes con apoyo de la guardia
nacional y la policía estatal el camión
fue llevado a una zona segura donde
fueron contabilizadas 154 personas
originarias de Guatemala 13 de Ecuador
tres del Salvador 3 de Honduras una de
República Dominicana y una de Pakistán
en una situación similar el gobierno
mexicano anunció el rescate de más de 40
migrantes secuestrados en un autobús al
norte del país el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador
alertó sobre el aumento de secuestros a
migrantes en México hay bandas
que secuestran por eso también
el llamamiento
a los hermanos migrantes
que no se dejen
engañar manipular
por los traficantes las bandas de
contrabandistas de migrantes conocidos
popularmente Como coyotes son individuos
que operan en los pasos fronterizos de
México y que ofrecen llevar a los
migrantes por territorio Azteca
prometiendo el sueño estadounidense un
sueño que muchas veces se convierte en
pesa